since i wasn't here
for the first three days of the workshop
i don't know if
how much of chronic care questions were
discussed already so if i repeat
something
i'm sorry
let me know if i need to skip some
so
what are these chronic air coefficients
well we have irreducible representations
of the symmetric group their index by
partitions of n and
natural operation one can do with this
reducible representations is of course
taking their tensor product
which is again a representation of sn
and
asking how does it decompose into
irreducibles
and
the multiplicities of the reducibles are
exactly these chronic year coefficients
so they're indexed by three the three
partitions lambda mu and mu
and uh
as turns out it's actually just they're
symmetric upon permutation of lambda mu
nu so that's why we actually
in my talk um we're writing them as a
as a sequence so one of them you're new
doesn't matter which one is on top
and uh
they also have interpretation in terms
of uh
gln modules well glm and glm squared
modules
and they can be thought of
in this language as well the
representations of the general linear
group
and uh
sometimes they get
very off so they get very often confused
with the little richardson coefficients
which are
the same
so the analogous structure constants but
this time for the
pro
representations of the general linear
group so if we have two
irreducible representations of gln
then they decompose
the direct sum of other irreducible
representations of geon and the
multiplicity is the little richardson in
this case
and uh
so there are various problems related to
the chronic your coefficients
one of them is
well the whole
75 or six years old problem of finding
some kind of combinatorial
interpretation for these coefficients
well there are of course non-negative
integers so they could be counting some
kind of combinatorial
discrete objects defined by
lambda mu and mu
and the motivation of course is that the
analogous little wood richardson
coefficients do have a combinatorial
interpretation in fact they are counting
uh this so-called little richard
centablo
and here is an example of what these
guys sort of look like so yeah discrete
objects
it's actually possible to encode them
polynomial in terms of the input and so
on but we'll talk about this
later
and
just to continue with
the connection so
it turns out that
for special cases of partitions
the chronic your coefficient is actually
equal to
uh little wood richardson coefficient so
in these cases we
just thanks to
thanks to the combinatorial
interpretation for little wood
richardson we also have
this case like combinatorial
interpretation for the chronic air
coefficients
well of course
people in combinatorics want something
more general than that so that works
and
in terms of combinatorics what is known
in terms of this question
well
so
the first results came
like 50 years after mourinho posed the
question
these are special cases when two of the
partitions are hooks
then later we had a result when
one of the partition is has two rows or
only two parts
but then there are restrictions and
there are very serious restrictions on
the size of
the first size of one of the
the size of the first part of one of the
other partitions for example
and
if i'm not misinterpreting this result
so when two of the partitions are
two rows
there is also
an interpretation and maybe the
most the best or the most general
interpretation is due to jonah blasik
very recent when one partition is a hook
and
the other two partitions can be anything
so this is really what we have so far as
you can see we're quite limited
now why are we talking about this call
this chronic here coefficients in this
workshop to begin with
well there
also come
in geometric complexity theory
so now these are
their problems about
deciding whether the chronic here
coefficient is zero and actually
computing it so
here
the
the way that the problems are phrased we
have input our partitions
are encoded a sequence of parts so the
size of the input
is l log is an order of log n where n is
the maximal
part size of this partitions when this
is in binary
but actually you can ask the same
questions even if the input was in unary
and as more or less
the same
lack of
answer
so
here are the
the conjectures part of
gct
so first is that the decision problem is
actually
polynomial
whether the chronicler coefficient is
non-zero
and uh
computing the chronic error coefficient
is
well conjectured to be in sharp p
and uh
so what is the state of the art of these
conjectures
well first of all
we don't even know whether the decision
problem is in np
because
so
the lack of any kind of combinatorial
interpretation
so of course there could be some other
reason why how you can decide that the
the
in this case the positivity of the
chronic here coefficients but
combinatorial interpretation possibly
would resolve the np and sharpie
questions
so if they are counting some kind of
reasonable combinatorial objects then
yeah probably there will be
in np and sharpie but even
that is not enough actually to prove
that this is polynomial
the decision problem would be polynomial
so
of course the analogous question for
little richardson questions actually
holds so
computing them is in sharpie and
deciding whether they are zero or not is
polynomial but the polynomiality is
highly non-trivial result
due to
tier uh
due to nuts knucksan and tao from like
10 years ago
of course the combinatorial
interpretation
easily implied that they are in np
actually
15 years ago
okay
when i first saw the result it was 10
years ago i guess because
the counter didn't update
ah well
uh so he has some kind of some result
about
the fact that it is going to be sharpie
hard or
in fact uh
yeah sorry sorry about that but
to compute this whatever this little
coefficient each polynomial time i just
should decide whether it is zero or not
just to decide whether it's zero or not
otherwise they're actually yeah they're
pretty
pretty big
so the decision is polynomial otherwise
computing them is definitely
and uh so what about the chronic here
coefficients
well the best to the best of our
knowledge there in gapi
due to better burger serum nickel meyer
and
what is he doing here
asking so he
since he proved that little richardson
coefficients are sharp picard and since
their special case of chronic here then
they they're at least i mean there's not
nothing better than
that to hope for
okay so to decide chronic coefficient
being g or non-zero is also quality
polynomial hard
i'm going to understand this last year
let's compute them so there is
so there are two problems here kp is
like chronic your positivity this so
deciding and this chrome here
is just computing right so maybe i
should
i should just
have this
this will be showing up
this is the decision problem
those guys
and
conjecture is
this is
in the sherpa class
yeah so actually this crown is in gapi i
think that's just a typo yeah
oh i'm sorry okay
sorry sorcerer yeah so that's what i
mean
oh
yeah okay so
so we already we know that yeah so what
are the two
complete problems
you subtract
the two quantities you'll see
okay oh yeah
i'll show a formula and then you can see
why this is true
okay
so
now that we have well now that we know
what well
know what our objects are
so extent
what are the problems and what can we
really say about them so
so positivity this so first of all we
already have the
um
more merely conjectures about
deciding positivity
so yes we are interested in figuring out
when is the chronicler coefficient zero
or not even if we
maybe even if we are not actually able
to compute it or describe it
very well maybe there are other ways one
can figure this out
and
so another motivation of why one could
ask this question on its own
is uh
the following conjecture by jan saxo
which is motivated by a similar result
when
we have when we're dealing with
representations of
finite simple groups of lead types turns
out that there is a irreducible
character whose tensor squared contains
every irreducible representation
and then he naturally conjectured
how about the same question for the
symmetric group is there an irreducible
character who stands their square
contains
every irreducible representation
and in particular
can we
prove this for this uh carrot for the
character corresponding to the staircase
partition
staircase partition showing up once
again
so this is
our guy
and uh
or in other words showing that the
chronic your coefficient for
of this form
row k row k and u is greater than zero
for all partitions
and you
and so here
is a conjecture
the theorem holds for not the symmetric
group but for
finite simple groups
known
when for for the staircase but you only
have a staircase sometimes is that what
you're saying no no no no no no it's not
no
just a conjecture it's just a conjecture
for the staircase
two years ago to three years ago yeah so
this result is also recent and then
okay
so
here is what we can say about this
conjecture in this
again result of
emitted type but since we don't actually
have any
good tools to deal with the chronic
error coefficients
that's usually how results look like
here so
we know that
this tensor squared as in the saxel
conjecture contains
irreducible representations
corresponding to partitions that look
like that
so either have hook and some extra boxes
here or we have two rows and some extra
boxes here
and the so far
it's a teal
so
these extra boxes are only finitely made
because and the reason the reason is
that
we are doing this by hand in some sense
so there is
there is so well show it's not inherent
to the
yeah so that's what we could do
basically
using the method that i'll show in a
second and of course and uh the other
thing is that
if we replace the staircase by
some other partition that
necessarily has to be self-conjugate and
why should it be self-conjugate it needs
to contain
the one column the sign representation
so if we take this guy
so square minus a box
this is uh
the same results also hold so it's not
so presumably people
check this conjecture yeah some values
yeah so the student of sex will check
this
did they check it
or something
there is there is evidence yes
another question um
so
the staircase is not the largest
representation the largest
yes but but we but the problem with this
asymptotic shape is that it's very
difficult to kind of handle it or
describe it combinatorial
so
so dimension wise it's fine
the dimension of that one is smaller
than the square of the direction of the
stairs
yeah no no so of course the the square
of the dimension of these guys
has to be greater than uh you know
yeah but no one has checked this other
one i guess i don't know they also well
i mean for every end you have
different partition but
yeah so if you check this one it's
presumably the this
this one will also work
unless you have some issue i mean so one
who should be careful because
there are some constraints about the
durfee
size the durfee square of the two
partitions so if they're
um
your squares
multiplied
are less than the other the third
partition is the rp square then it's
gonna be zero so
yeah so
as long as that holds then we don't see
you have a
yeah so actually i mean it may not be
very relevant
but this staircase partition
uh appeared in my work with thompson
where we proved that this important
scheme
uh that the tourist fixed points are
authorized by
representation
and this staircase partition has the
property that every other fixed point is
in its closure
so it has a very important property
there and there is also the other thing
is i was going to say which is not
parallel the staircase shows up in
modular representations and also has
some
meaning in with in respect to this
conjecture so it's it's not a random
partition
yeah so that's
so okay
but you need to take a chopped square
you cannot just take a square
yes because the square does not contain
so this does not contain the
this guy here oh sure yes so
yeah
but apart from that it's also contains
many more
okay so let me say a little bit how we
go about proving whatever we proved so
here is a statement
which
is actually letting us compare chronic
your coefficient to the absolute value
of particular character so the character
this is just the character of the
represent corresponding representation
again of the symmetric group
and
what turns out is that if you have like
a self-conjugate partition
and you take this
g nu mu mu
so the multiplicity of
mu in the tensor squared it's actually
greater than or equal to absolute value
of the character of this same nu
evaluated that
these are the principal hooks of our
self-conjugate partition
that's all
and the way this proof works is that it
will reduce we reduce to
representations of the alternating group
and here is an example
so
mu our self-conjugate partition is this
one these are these principal hooks
and suppose that we take
new sorry there is another type mu to be
equal to the same partition
by the mourinho nakayama rule
there is only one murna ganakayama table
we can actually
fit inside here
so the character is plus or minus one
and necessarily this guy is greater than
zero so we have that if it's
if the partition is self-conjugated then
it the tensor squared contains
so itself
bracket
new hat i could just scare the value of
it the character the character
yes just the evaluation yeah okay
okay so
of course
the character happens to be zero and the
character itself is not easy to compute
because it's actually an alternating sum
of
many things
but uh so now now the question is how do
we go about computing it
and this is why
why we have the results we have it's
easy to com it's relatively easy to
compute it when we have
two rows and hooks enough i mean the
other cases follow analogously but we
have more complicated stuff here
basically in this case in these cases
the character is some kind of difference
between
the number of partitions
into parts of sizes these guys
and now
even that's not obviously known zero
element so it's
these were all partitions maybe yes but
so here we also need a result which
comes from us the symptotic analysis of
this partition function
this is telling us
that
this these guys are actually the number
of partitions are strictly increasing
from some point on
and then for the small values then we
can still actually
do this using whatever is available so
for example blasix combinatorial
interpretation for hooks
or uh
yeah
bro the result of
rosarian and
christina valentine about
two rows win special cases
yeah so this is defined as the number
here so
that's the definition
yeah you don't you don't repeat them so
that's
so this is really coming from mourinho
kayama rule of
uh
how you can fit
so this for so first of all there is
jacobi truly hidden in here
and then evaluating a character in just
one row
is just the number of partitions
so if you have two rows how you can
put the different um
strips into the different
into the two rows so this is just again
number of per number of ways to
create a partition
and okay so now that we have this
comparison between
chronic here and characters
and in this case we had that the
characters are positive
then we get the result for
two rows hooks and
and the other
special cases that i showed
now
i want to go into combinatorics
a little bit so how does
uh
so maybe i like to say something there
is
another recent result about the
axial conjecture
by myself that
that tells you the following this is
a general thing
if you take
the staircase partition okay
okay
and then take a third partition that is
let's say of that of the form n minus
e
and then nu bar so you have this three
partitions
and then you look at the quadratic
coefficient as a function of k
and this is piecewise polynomial
and then
you can prove that each of
this partition is containing infinitely
many
answers your category okay
this is like as a function of psn
for any fixed d there is a
is this how yeah
okay
yeah
yes
you have this coefficient
and then you look at this coefficient as
a function of k
and this function
as the function of k is piecewise
for any fixed d or six
which is
this number here that is at the end of
this partition
and uh
the principal coefficient is the number
of standard law of shape
new bar
so there is another
okay let's uh
let's discuss axle conjecture lit so i
want to
talk a little bit about
some
more combinatorial techniques or how one
can get a handle of these coefficients
and some other results that
that are more combinatorial in nature
so
here is basically a
background
i'm assuming that you probably know all
this but
in any case so if you
the symmetric functions if you consider
the ring of symmetric functions
then one of the most important
representatives of this ring are the
sure functions which are the characters
of the reducible
gl and representations evaluated at
the matrix the diagonal matrix with
these eigenvalues
and
uh so they correspond to the reducible
representations and they carry with them
the inner product which is inherent to
representation theory
and then we have the vile character
formula
which is expressing the sure functions
as ratio of two
determinants
this is the van der man de term uh van
der monde matrix here so just
the product of all the pairwise
differences
and
from one hand we have this formula on
the other hand we also have
combinatorial interpretation
which is uh
that the sure function is the sum over
all semi standard young tableau
of
whatever partition this corresponds to
and then we take
the the monomial so we are filling every
box with the corresponding variable and
then we just multiply them out
for each semi-standard yen table and
this is in this case for example what we
get if we have three variables
and uh
so
then there is
so there is a chronic ear product which
corresponds comes from the
characteristic map on the symmetric
group and this actually corresponds to
uh the irreducible representations of sn
so if we take
you can think of this uh
really informally if we replace the sure
functions by the corresponding
modules and this star by the tensor
product
so this is really
what this the what this is these are the
chronic your coefficient in this case so
if we take
uh
this chronic here product of two sure
functions we get exactly decomposes as
sum of sure functions exactly with
multiplicities the chronic error
coefficient
and uh that's the definition of this
star product yes that's like you can
think of it as definition of the star
product
so there are also other equivalent ways
of defining it
for example this one
and
so so here is one identity which i like
to call generalized kushi because there
is crochet identity when you have only
two sets of variables
and this is that if you have three sets
of variables x y and z and you take all
the
pairwise products of partitions of the
same size lambda mu and u
and you weight them by the chronic your
coefficient you just get this product
here
so
that's uh so that's a really nice
formula
and another way of getting the chronic
your coefficients is is by
this sort of
logistic evaluation of one sure function
at the pairwise
at this x times y where you actually
take all
the variables are all the possible
pairwise products between x's and y's
and when you evaluate this is of course
going to be a symmetric function in x
and in y you can expand it
in the basis of symmetric functions in s
in x and y
and you can take again coefficient in
that expansion in the
terms of the sure function
and this is like the more general
formula is this one here so if you have
any you can take inner product with any
three symmetric functions
this is what it means
and
so uh and uh
another
way so you can you can get the
coefficient in front of of
the in terms if we expand our symmetric
functions in terms of short functions
one way to figure out what the
coefficient of the corresponding sure
function is going to be is actually
using
about the terminal formula and taking a
particular monomial
so if we multiply by the van der mant
our symmetric function
then it's going to split up into
distinct monomials like that the
corresponding coefficient for the sure
function can be derived as
a monomial coefficient in this case
so
basically now we're
we can translate
the representation theory in terms of
symmetric functions and work with them
maybe because
it could be easier or at least it could
be easier to get a handle on how things
behave
there's a number it's like that number
yes yes and this is this is this is
coefficient of this monomial
so everything means square so when we
have these square brackets it's like
coefficient in
in whatever
expansion makes sense in this case
so let's do a toy example also now that
somebody asked this on matt overflow i
can legitimately give this as an example
of how one can use this
there is
a person observed that
uh
if we if you take chronic your
coefficient for
these three rectangles so
this is
m repeated n times l times this is
l m repeated n times and so on
then this chronic your coefficient is
one
and asked for a simple reason why this
is true and
so here is how one can get this out of
sure functions
so
remember the platistic interpretation we
have as
lambda
evaluated at x times y is actually equal
to this
sum
in terms of chronic year coefficient so
in particular
if you take if you get whatever sure
whatever you're interested in
you have those sure functions plus
something else and now you can actually
specialize and
plug in only
a limited number of variables in here
and exactly as many that
just from the combinatorial
interpretation
just because we have exactly end time
cell variables and this is a rectangle
wait wait sorry
what yeah don't you have to some of what
we were new
yeah so so just that you know that these
other guys are positive
oh okay so now i can limit my the number
of variables here
so x1 x1 to xn y's y1 to yl
then this pairwise products has n times
l variables and if you evaluate
if there is only one semi standard young
tableau
of this shape and
m by n times l
with n times l variables so
you actually
get this guy which is of course the
product of these other rectangles so
it's actually equal to
the product of these two sure functions
and now
by this comparing with this formula we
get that the chronic equation has to be
one in this particular case
and so
and of course so one can play this this
game anytime you have as many variables
as heights you know that you already get
some kind of call
okay so
um
well i mean i was just i was just trying
to give an example of how the technique
works i'm not claiming any kind of
ownership here just somebody else this
will not overflow here is an easy answer
i'm just trying to
show how it could work so
i don't know
so
okay so let's talk a little bit about uh
combinatorics further and how these
computations can help with other things
so if we
consider partitions that fit inside a
rectangle their generating function is
the q binomial
coefficient very nice easy combinatorial
object
and
so these numbers this is just the number
of partitions that fit inside a
rectangle and has n parts
and
so
and it's not so
easy to see that these numbers are
actually your new model so
they are weakly increasing up to the
middle the number of partitions and then
weekly decreasing
so one can think of okay so there's
there should be some kind of bijection
or inclusion and stuff like that but the
truth is that
when sylvester proved this
he was so proud of himself that he wrote
this and
so
a quarter of a century is an old
conjecture too oh yeah
so but the queen now
how did he prove this
this is another quote from
from his paper
well yeah i'm so modest
person what can you say
seem more interesting
actually yes because the is
i don't know i
never
never had the nerves of going through
all the
details so
so then there were actually some other
proofs
uh first stanley used the heart left
shoulders theorem actually it's
interesting to note
that this hard lapses theorem in the
simple consequence of the cell to
representation theory yes yes
yes you realize that this is connected
yeah
and we'll complete it once again so
loop around again
so
yeah so there is also linear simple
linear algebra involved which is more or
less
demystifying this kind of proof and sl2
action
and at the
like 24 years ago
katie o'hare
actually
gave a constructive combinatorial proof
which
basically interprets these numbers as
counting something and
being one the larger one subset of the
other
so
now
what do these numbers have to do with
anything
so let's take a step back and consider
this sort of
quantity so this is a sum over little
products of little wood richardson
coefficient
well using this sure function technique
one can actually represent the chronic
here coefficient as difference of two
consecutive
of these numbers like k is
the size of one of the partitions
involved
and now just
just because these chronic your
coefficients are always non-negative
by counting represe
multiplicities of representations
we know that this sequence has to be
actually unimodal
that or in other words that these
numbers are greater than or equal to
zero the difference
and the proof goes true
goes through for example one can do this
simply with again this symmetric
function type computation
uh again taking coefficients and using
the
so products the little wood richardson
coefficient they simply come out from
these products
sure functions here
and as i already remarked the fact that
the chronic er coefficients are
non-negative we have this inequalities
and now
okay so this is some kind of mysterious
sum here so what does this have to do
with partitions in a rectangle well the
following so if we actually take
lambda and mu here to be
the rectangle for the
rectangles themselves then it's very
easy to see that
the little richardson coefficients are
just 0 and 1
and in fact
for each partition that fits in the
rectangle
we have exactly one partition
better for which this is exactly one
and in this case this coefficient then
just counting the number of partitions
that fit inside the
rectangle
and now we get
this formula that
the chronic error coefficient for two
rectangles and a two row is actually the
difference of
the consecutive
numbers in the q binomial coefficient
expansion or exactly what sylvester was
actually counting
and
so this sylvester's theorem is one
corollary
but another
another corollary of of this fact is
actually that one can get bounce on this
differences actually effective bounds on
how
much larger the next number of
partitions is
and so here is
an effective bound
how is it obtained well it's obtained
using two things first
using the fact that this difference this
the this difference is the chronic your
coefficient and then using this
character lemma
which i showed earlier that
this chronic your coefficient is greater
than or equal to the character
and then we can actually do some
asymptotics on this particular character
and get
these numbers here
and this is not
anything that was
so just using pure algebra
that so the neither sylvester nor
stanley
had actual
uh bounds like that
and of course if so this is in the case
of uh
in this in partitions in a square and in
the more general case it uses the
monotonicity property
to manifest in uh that the chronic your
coefficients are actually weakly
increasing as long as you are adding
partitions so such that
this chronic error is
strictly positive
and
there is another thing that you can say
about this now that we actually have
some kind of combinatorial
interpretation
for the q binomial coefficients other
than
the partitions
one can actually take the difference
between the two things and use ocarist
combinatorial proof why these numbers
are increasing
to actually give a
combinatorial interpretation
for the chronic your coefficients in
these particular cases
and
actual combinatorial interpretation
which is
manageable in size
now i'm not going to state it right now
here because it's it's not something
very particularly pretty but it is
actually explicit and
not so big it's in terms of certain
kinds of
trees
and
of course they are so this
implies that
this chronic year coefficient is going
to be in sharp p
and
the other case when
the chronic here coefficient is in sharp
p that we know
for example is
the corollary of blasik's combinatorial
interpretation where we have a hook
and of course then the decision problem
is also in np
but still we don't know anything about
whether it's polynomial or not
and uh
so this is this brings us to the topic
of complexity finally and some sort of
running out of time so i will just
state some results here
so here is
an explicit
upper bound in the time required
to compute chronic your coefficient in
terms of
three quantities so the length of the
partitions
their largest part size and and
the second part of one of the
partitions involved
so basically we have
partitions with at most
with
at most l parts and at most
the largest part is at most n
and uh
and so and here the second
the second row of nu
is let's say bounded by some other
parameter m
then you can
say something like some kind of refined
estimate of how long it can take
to
compute the chronic your coefficients in
terms of this
and in particular if
you get
small enough values then you can
actually get a polynomial time algorithm
so as long as
you can represent this in
polynomial in terms of them
second part so this is like the
second row of one of the partitions but
the second has to be very small
yeah well
if it's on the order of n then you're
not really getting much but if it's
actually small then maybe you can get
some
and of course we have
when m is on the order of n
and uh l is actually fixed we get the
result of
chris standaldorn and valtter which
probably you guys saw earlier this week
then this is actually
you can compute this in polynomial time
as long as this exponents are
fixed so partitions of fixed length
but
and here is one other result about this
computation which is
that you can actually decide
if you have
number of parts fixed you can actually
decide the
linear time whether the chronicler
coefficient is greater than zero
but
not just polynomial but linear but this
is not
a real algorithm so why is it not
because it relies on the existence of
the finite generating set for the semi
group of chronic ear coefficients so it
the semi group is finitely generated so
for for each fixed l
so
if you actually know the generators then
yes so you can thanks to results in
integer linear programming you can
decide whether
this guy
belongs to the semi group or not of
course
i was just saying this is like pure
purely purely
yeah
yeah so we don't know the constant so we
don't actually know
it's this is a theoretical result so we
don't know that
how big is the
how big is the generating set for the
semi semi group so
it's not even we don't even know how to
actually find it also it's
so this is just a
theoretical thing
but so it's not an algorithm it's just a
the statement of what is just
generating things
i don't know
i mean
i
haven't thought about this but
i don't i don't even know how to go
about this
and
so i just mentioned how
this these bounds are obtained well
they're relying on on two two facts one
is that
if you are consider if you consider
the second part of one of these
partitions and depending on
how large it is you can actually reduce
your chronic your coefficient
from computing g lambda mu nu to
computing g of partitions which are much
smaller of size that depends on the
second parts of n
of newt
of one of the partitions
and there they're actually explicitly
defined as partitions you're actually
subtracting
some specific partitions out of them
big maybe probably big
and uh actually if you add again this
this semi group property
the fact that you can go down also means
that
if you go up to too much you are going
to get a constant
uh
chronic your coefficient so
you can
you can translate this statement also in
terms of what's called now more
generalized ability so if you're
adding
multiples of a partition to two of the
partitions and the long row then
eventually this stabilizes so it becomes
constant
and this was uh
but the last one you are only adding
this box
so you're in the last one you're only
adding a
long row
the sizes need to be
and there are actually a means for in
terms of stability there actually
the state of the art is a paper by
ernesto
that just came out a few weeks ago which
is has more general statements than this
one
and okay so
now that somebody else asked about sharp
gap p
well
there is a way to express
this chronic air coefficient as an
alternating sum over
number of contingency tables well
contingency arrays three byte with
three-dimensional contingency arrays
with certain
um
two-dimensional marginals
and of course
if you group the positive and the
negative
you get you get two quantities that are
both the difference of two quantities
that are both uh
positive and
combinatorially very
very nice objects so that's one way
to show the gap p result
but also you can use this
formula as
again christine aldoran and walter did
is actually you can
compute the chronic your coefficients by
computing the number of contingency
tables and they can be done with
barbinox algorithm
in a specific certain
amount of time
and
so so basically this is on the
combination of this and this is telling
you just in general how
how
easy you can compute the chronic your
coefficient
and
and then using the reduction lemma and
together with this guy so once we
get from bigger coefficients to smaller
coefficients now we we just use this
this bound and that's basically what
happens here
and only the last the last thing is i
that uh
last result is
if you remember in the beginning where
there was this character lemma bounding
chronicler coefficients with characters
well unfortunately maybe this is not the
right approach because actually deciding
whether the character is zero or not is
np hard
the character deciding whether it's zero
or not
in terms of the two inputs so partition
and conjugacy class written as in this
form
this is actually np hard
and
actually the very last remark you said
kai lambda mu is empty hard deciding if
it's zero or not yeah right now
is it by the project and maybe there is
some some some brilliant method to
calculate right and it's
impossible
so the words
means by the methods are there cannot be
any way to assuming these not equal
things so assuming p is not equal to np
though in special cases of this
partition this character is actually
computing it
is actually equivalent to solving a
knapsack problem so
yeah
this discussion so if if you had an
oracle which gave you the character
table for your given symmetric group for
any size
of course you just said this is going to
be hard but doesn't that
didn't tell you that coefficient it's
also np hard because you can just
project from from that problem to your
problem you have a
easy way to go from the character table
to computing the chronicler coefficient
the characteristic is hard so yeah so
okay so this it works in one way from if
you have the character table you can
compute the chronic error but the
problem is not conversely yes
yeah so the chronic here will be
probably something much smaller because
it's going to be a
some kind of alternating some of
these huge characters who
so for
geometric complexity here the most
interest is around the quantifier where
two of the partitions are boxes
the third is very long first part not
too many parts
well so
you had one result where you had box box
and something else but it was the ones
they also did another one whereas the
right something else but it wasn't with
box box so but the other one is you can
specialize with the boxes and in fact
we had an email discussion about this
with the
that you can reduce from the
the from the rectangles you can get to
much smaller rectangles but
box box is the worst actually
it looks simple but it is the most yeah
can you turn to the slide
so is it conceivable that this is hard
also when
london you are very respected
so can you read through the proofs also
so this comes from lambda being two rows
or even four that's two rows
well
i mean it's all it's already flame
there's two rows so you're all ready
it's already pretty bad
even if could spell
that well no so i think that no if you
fix cell it's not going to be empty